[Musique]
je suis de gauche je signale j'te filmé
de dos au maire d'axât lyon va pas trop
joli visage était trop belle qu'est-ce
que tu es belle
oui ça va attention ils doivent être
jaloux tu regardes tu devrais oui qu'est
ce que c'est encore les deux côtés
[Rires]
d'abord c'est que le début d'accord ça a
été dur confie ses six ans jean raspail
et à l'horizon là et avec qui célèbre en
même temps comment je suis léveillé
c'est vrai à 34 ans boca singes en place
quelque 35 36 36 chez foot locker
quoi quoi quoi et ça raphaëlle bacqué
leaf qui sera va vous aider
tu veux c'est ce que nous a dit tout à
l'heure elle passe un mois et demi avant
donc à moi il va nous rester beaucoup à
manger
chérèque je vous invite à dîner ton
frère après tout ce n'est pas tu n'es
pas ma vie dérangeant vous souhaitez
génial c'est pas parce que j'ai dû lire
[Musique]
je suis avec donald reignoux sa nouvelle
ça va très bien qu est ce que dirait
peter parker alias spiderman pour le
replay est de cette édition un grand
replay implique de grandes
responsabilités
c'est très bien et notre ami titeuf il
est d'accord avec sa voiture contre
j'aime l'art et montrant qu'elle est un
acte en attendant merci à mordelles
ah le bata
pieds de lui offrir
s'il a laissé participants directs
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]